in one of the most hypocritical elements
of the Trump family you might remember
that after months of crowing about
illegals and deportation and all that
stuff by Donald Trump during his
campaign really serious questions came
up about Melania Trump's immigration
status in the US and by all accounts we
now have realized that she was in the
United States working illegally for some
time right Trump the law and order
everybody's got to come in the legal way
or they got to go out and try to come
back in is married to a woman who was in
the United States on a visa that did not
allow her to work and she was working
that is against the law and we were told
when these allegations surfaced that
eventually they were gonna have a press
conference where it was all going to be
explained but they never held that press
conference we're still waiting and that
was about 18 months ago so it's probably
never going to happen but there's now a
new layer to the Trump family hypocrisy
on immigration Donald Trump has been
staunchly and aggressively against
so-called chain migration chain
migration is part of the American visa
program and that lets immigrants who are
already here petition legally to bring
family members over okay there's another
name for it which is called family
reunification and it turns out that
milania's own parents have been living
in the United States for at least a year
according to numerous reports and more
and more it seems like they are here
because of chain migration so a number
of spokespeople for Melania Trump and
for the White House have refused to say
what the legal status of Melania Trump
parents is and of course one possibility
is milania's parents could be here on IR
five visas meaning they're legal
permanent residents
another possibility is they are here on
tourism visas but they have extensions
to those visas but when a spokeswoman
was asked are they here on IR 5s are
they here on extended tourist visas the
Washington Post was told no none of
those options apply to their situations
so again this points more and more to
the policy that Trump says shouldn't
exist being the reason why Melania
parents are here chain migration and I
want to refresh this idea because it's
more relevant now than ever
you can tell Trump's real views on
something by what he does in business
and by what he does in his life right if
his personal view is the right one he
will still legislate on his boat bogus
fake view and that's bad but what you
ultimately come to sort of if you follow
this all the way through is a position
where at least for the purposes of Trump
the president if not Trump the
businessman or Trump the private citizen
you get to a position where well I guess
he's against chain migration as
president specifically for Muslims and
brown people but he's okay with it
especially personally for the parents of
European models and presumably for based
on Trump's past comment when it's white
people from Norway then chain migration
maybe is okay now I want to be super
clear I don't want Melania Trump spare
ins deported
I don't want chain migration ended I
just want the hypocrisy to stop or for
someone to hold Trump accountable for
the hypocrisy because it wasn't that
long ago
and especially for Republicans as well
it wasn't long ago when Republicans were
making fun of John Kerry because his
wife was foreign and she spoke another
language and so did Trump just make the
hypocrisy end that's what I want yeah
and Kerry was a flip-flopper too so they
said I think it's because you can't
really pin Trump down he doesn't really
have a specific ideology
he's been contradicting himself for
years he became against a portion at the
age of 68 or 69 yeah and he advocates
one tax policy seems to benefit from
another you could call that not knowing
anything but the right has sort of
defended it by saying well he's an
outsider to politics so that's why he's
sort of figuring out his positions but
it's all total and utter hypocrisy and
one one last tiny bit of non outrage
that would be outraged if it were
related to Obama Melania Trump's dad who
again is likely in the US on chain
migration because of chain migration
which Trump opposes Melania Trump's dad
is a former member of the Yugoslavs
Communist Party can you imagine for a
fraction of a second if Michelle Obama's
father had once been a member of a
foreign countries Communist Party what
would have taken place think about it
you don't even have to answer and Pat's
coming up with answers but we we all
know exactly what it is that would have
happened on right-wing media if Michelle
Obama's dad was a former member of the
whatever Slovakian Communist Party oh no
we I mean we can't talk about milania's
parents because they're living their
private lives of course so we can't also
talk about Michelle Obama's parents
either yeah totally different standard
as usual chain migration what else can
we say
now this is something you can discuss on
our subreddit if you want at david
pakman.com slash re d di t we'll take a
quick break we've got a great interview
coming up for you today today's episode
of the show is made possible in part by
brilliant which is really an amazing
website that lets you engage in fun and
interesting problems and puzzles to
learn more about really important stuff
math science engineering the community
aspect of brilliant is great there's
over five million members there bringing
together the knowledge and experience of
their students their educators the
professionals around the world that
develop a lot of the hands-on learning
problems that you will work through and
learning with a community makes a huge
difference right when you use brilliant
you're part of that 5 million member
community they share your curiosity and
love for math and science and the
community at brilliant also supports
your learning because you build a
connection with the subjects you're
learning by interacting with other
people studying the same material you
can get started right now by signing up
for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman first two hundred people who
visit brilliant org slash David Pakman
will get 20% off an annual premium
membership that is brilliant org forward
slash David Pakman support us by
supporting brilliant